what's going on theo this is julian
powers
colin from niagara falls canada what's
up julian
and that's a clean water thoroughfare up
there
niagara man i want to thank you too
because we drink a lot of that
and we've been sipping off of y'all for
a while sucking off that clean titty
while we down here flinting
gang [ __ ] homer and i had a question for
you
so i'm 21 years old i just moved out of
my house for the first time i'm ready to
take on the world
and i was wondering what you would tell
yourself if you could speak to your 21
year old self
because i'm out you're trying to get
some life experience
and i think i have big dreams for myself
but you know
i easily stop myself from achieving
those dreams
um i'm my own worst enemy in a lot of
ways maybe it's a lack of belief
maybe i just don't have the right tools
i don't know i think i have everything i
need in me but i just got to get my
brain right but
i'd be very interested in knowing what
you would tell your 21 year old self
gang brother thanks julian for that
question man um
you know
what would i tell my 21 year old self
i would say ask her out
no matter who she is whether she's a job
or a new city
or or a
actual person
you know whether whether she's
uh an opportunity
or a fear
you know if you're afraid of heights ask
her out
hey heights what you doing tonight
even though i recommend doing heights
during the daytime when you can see
what's going on but
you know like whatever she is man ask
her out
you know the saddest things in my life i
remember almost touching a girl's body
one time and uh she wanted me to
so i wasn't you know everybody was awake
and but uh
but i didn't try to
and she was beautiful
and i was beautiful dude i was young
and man i just if i could go back to
that moment
and just not be afraid just
just recognize that i look whatever
could be out there i could have it
man that was you know so ask her out
whatever she is
um what else would i tell myself
everything's gonna be okay
everything you're worried about is gonna
be okay
that too whatever it is that also
is going to be fine uh try some
mushrooms man have a few more mushrooms
here and there
do it in a safe environment you know
don't drive while you're doing it but do
it somewhere have fun
find people that you care about that you
can listen to
and that will listen to you
um
what else would i tell my 21 year old
self
take a chance man you know i remember
when i was uh
i don't know some type of age but
my best friend scott his dad i was
asking i was thinking
you know should i move to los angeles
and he said yes
yes you should i said well why does he
goes because you can always come back
you can always come back whatever you
can always come back
throughout my life i've been back home
to my you know my louisiana homes
50 times you can always come back
whatever that thing is that's a
possibility
go grab that [ __ ] by the nut
smoke my natch fam you got to get out
there
whatever it is ask her out
and i yeah and he was right if that man
had never said hey you should go do that
i never would have i never would have
tried to go do comedy or do this
or do go to los angeles he said you can
always come back
go do it you'll never have that freedom
like you do when you're
21 whatever age you know he didn't
specify because i don't know what age i
was
but time yeah time slow slow in the
beginning
and then that [ __ ] will [ __ ] usain
on you son
so
but you're gonna be fine man no matter
what you're gonna be okay just remember
that you already are okay
so you got this baby boy and i love you
man and i'm excited for you
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you could watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah